[Music]
I define intelligence as how good
something is at accomplishing complex
goals so let's unpack that a little bit
first of all it's a spectrum of
abilities since there are many different
goals you could have right so it makes
no sense to quantify something's
intelligence by just one number to see
how ridiculous that would be just
imagine if I told you that athletic
ability could be quantified by a single
number the athletic quotient and
whatever athlete had the highest IQ
would win all the gold medals in the
Olympics it's the same with intelligence
so it's if you have a machine that's
pretty good at some tasks these days
it's usually pretty narrow intelligence
maybe the machine is very good at
multiplying numbers fast because it's
your pocket calculator maybe it's good
at driving cars or playing go humans on
the other hand have a remarkably broad
intelligence a human child can learn
almost anything given enough time even
even though we now have machines that
can learn and sometimes learn to do
certain narrow tasks better than humans
machine learning is still very
unimpressive compared to human learnings
for example it might take a machine pens
of thousands of pictures of cats and
dogs until it becomes able to tell a cat
from a dog whereas human children can
sometimes learn what a cat is from we're
seeing it once another area where we
have a long way to go in AI is
generalizing if a human learns to play
one particular kind of game they can
very quickly take that knowledge apply
it to some other kind of game or some
other life situation altogether and
there's this is a fascinating frontier
of AI research now how can we have
machines ok make them as good at
learning from very limited data as
people are and I think part of the
challenge is that we humans aren't just
learning to recognize some patterns we
also gradually learn to develop a whole
model of the world so if you ask
are the machines that are more
intelligent that people today there are
machines that are better than us it's
accomplishing some goals the absolutely
not all goals AGI artificial general
intelligence that's the dream of the
field of AI to build a machine that's
better than us at all goals we're not
there yet but a good fraction of leading
AI researchers think we are gonna get
there maybe in in a few decades and if
that happens you have to ask yourself if
that might lead the machines getting not
just a little better than us but way
better at all goals having super
intelligence and the argument for that
is actually really interesting goes back
to the 60s to the mathematician IJ Goode
who pointed out that the goal of
building an intelligent machine is in
and of itself something that you could
do with intelligence so if once you get
machines that are better than us at that
narrow task of building AI then future a
eyes can be built by not human engineers
but by machines except they might do it
thousands or a million times faster so
in in my book I explore this scenario
you have this computer called Prometheus
which has vastly more hardware than than
a human brain does and it's still very
limited by its software being kind of
dumb and but at the point where it gets
human level general intelligence first
thing it does is it uses this to realize
how I can reprogram my software to
become much better and now it's a lot
smarter and then a few minutes later it
does this again and then it does it
again and does it again and in a matter
of perhaps a few days or weeks a machine
like that might be able to become not
just a little bit smarter than us but
leave us far far behind I think a lot of
people dismiss this kind of talk of
super intelligence as science fiction
because we're stuck in this sort of
carbon chauvinism idea that intelligence
can only exist in biological organisms
made of cells and carbon atoms
and as as a physicist from my
perspective intelligence is just kind of
information processing performed by
elementary particles moving around you
know according to the laws of physics
and there's absolutely no law of physics
that says that you can't do that in ways
that are much more intelligent than
humans we're so limited by how much
brain matter fits through mommy's birth
canal and stuff like this and machines
are not so I think it's very likely that
once machines reach a human level
they're not going to stop there they'll
just blow right by and that we might one
day have machines that are as much
smarter than us as we are smarter than
snails
[Music]